un nuevo reto diario para los habitantes
de haití conseguir agua mientras algunos
compran en las calles los contenedores
de líquido por unos 15 centavos de dólar
otros optan por recoger las aguas de la
lluvia la cual ahorran y reutilizan
tenemos una estrategia que consiste en
almacenar el agua que utilizamos para
lavar la ropa y con ella luego lavamos
los baños cuando llueve ahorramos mucha
agua la flor amos y la utilizamos para
cocinar hablando la visual además de la
crisis política y los estragos del
terremoto de agosto en haití ahora se
sienten las repercusiones de la falta de
combustible bandas armadas mantienen
bloqueos en los puertos donde se
almacena la gasolina necesaria para el
funcionamiento de las estaciones de
bombeo de agua con esta medida los
grupos armados buscan presionar la
renuncia del primer ministro ariel henry
no tenemos grandes infraestructuras
secuestradas por grupos armados
utilizamos varios medios para
explicarles que el agua es una necesidad
pública algunos me entienden pero otros
no aceptan el mensaje en la región de
puerto príncipe de los municipios más
afectados son del más está barre y
ciudad del sol una situación similar en
frente a la ciudad de juana méndez
situada en la frontera con la república
dominicana haití ha estado luchando
contra la escasez y la anarquía tras el
asesinato del presidente yo en el movice
en julio según el banco mundial sólo la
mitad de la población de haití tiene
acceso a agua potable y sólo un tercio a
la sanidad básica estadísticas que
podrían deteriorarse si los bloqueos
perduran